[Music]
republicans getting their chance to
grill big tech ceos over
allegations of censorship the heads of
twitter facebook and google
all testifying today before a senate
committee watch this
mr dorsey who the hell elected
you and put you in charge of what the
media are allowed to report and what the
american people are allowed to hear
and why do you persist in behaving as a
democratic
super pac silencing views to the
contrary
your political belief we're not doing
that uh and this is why i opened
um this hearing with calls for more
transparency
can you name for me one high-profile
person or
entity from a liberal ideology who you
have censored senator i need to i need
to think about it and
and get you more of a list
jesse i i just thought to myself it
looks like
they're concerned about censorship but
at the same time whenever i look at
facebook it's like nine of the top ten
posts come from president trump
come from ben shapiro and other
conservatives so
why is the right wing saying they're
being censored
because they are juan imagine it would
probably be all 10 out of 10 would have
the most traffic
on facebook if there wasn't censorship i
don't know i'm trying really hard not to
talk about jack dorsey's beard i made a
commitment in the beginning of the year
i wasn't going to mention physical
appearance
so i'm just going to try to stay with
that but juan i mean it's clear
they couldn't name one liberal
organization
one prominent democrat that they've ever
flagged for censorship
yet i could name dozens of conservatives
off the top of my head
right now that have been censored they
say oh
right now we don't know you know any
evidence
if there was any russia disinformation
with hunter biden
no evidence of hacking and no evidence
that it was forgeries
yet you still the new york post can't
tweet that article out
and they say we have all these fact
checkers looking into it and then bob
olinsky told tucker carlson
not one representative from twitter or
facebook has called him to help verify
the story
so they you know we bring these guys in
every couple months
they say they don't discriminate then
they fly home and discriminate i'm sick
of it
huh well you know to my mind greg i
think that these big companies
love clicks because clicks equal money
so they look the other way
on disinformation most of the time
uh well i don't know you gotta uh when
uh twitter blocks kaylee mcinanny but
not the ayatollah
not the king of death to america there's
something going on here
i am just wondering where the
traditional liberals went the free
speech absolutists they were the ones
that were always on this side
and now they're not and they're on the
side of a
of an entity that is about controlling
narratives it's not about it since
you don't cure censorship with more
censorship so it's it's it's bizarre
that we're even having this discussion
but you have to look
at what they're doing they're
controlling stories they're controlling
narratives through algorithms
that is the scary part of this
well dana isn't it right to warn people
about a post that says
mass don't save lives
i think here's the thing is that under
the law
as it was written in 1996 when the
internet was just getting started
the section 230 basically what it says
is
you cannot be sued or held liable for
anything that is that somebody else
posts on your site
but it also said that you are a private
company and therefore you are allowed to
do whatever you want
so as neil ferguson said today on the
daily briefing um it's a catch-22
for the consumer like or of the
information
and this is what i think when you saw
ted cruz today
make that statement in the way that he
did even though this was an issue in
2016 and nobody did
anything and now we're in 2020. i think
this is going to be
an issue that republicans and democrats
both try to
run on in 2024 in the meantime
technology continues to grow by leaps
and bounds
so washington is always so far behind
where these guys are
kennedy what do you think about
conservatives suddenly trying to
regulate
private business i'm not a fan of it but
i
i don't think these big tech
corporations have to worry about
conservatives as much in terms of that
1996 law that dana just pointed out
as people like elizabeth warren and if
she becomes a part of
the biden administration if he's elected
then she's going to do whatever she can
if if she is labor secretary or treasury
secretary to dismantle these companies
and take them apart because i i think
you have a pretty robust
anti-trust appetite when it comes to big
tech companies
and that's from both sides so it's very
interesting that
uh that employees of these companies
have poured so much money
into joe biden's campaign and other
democrat races
because it's democrats who want to take
them apart
and republicans who are looking for this
federal imposition of fairness and jack
dorsey
perjured himself today when he said that
the new york post story
is available for retweet it is not you
cannot access it and you cannot retweet
it
and that is a lie and he is the ceo of
that company
and he knows better
all right thanks kennedy